ROBERT TOWNSEND: Welcome,
everybody, today,
for the next segment
of the class.
Actually, this is
literally a continuation.
It's not a sharp break between
the last lecture and today.
Fortunately, the
lecture today has
some repeat of the equations,
or at least a version
of those equations.
Plus, I know you're all
totally fresh from the exam,
so you know what the
last lecture was anyway.
Just teasing you a little bit.
Sorry.
I'll just say a few
words about the calendar.
So we are right here,
today, Thursday, 10/1.
Oh, my goodness.
It is October.
And we're going to do
risk-sharing applications today
and then also 9.
Although this says
risk-sharing applications,
I want to feature that we'll
combine it with a production
even in a more direct
way than we will today.
So two lectures today, Thursday
and Tuesday, on risk-sharing.
So that's the calendar.
The second thing would
be the reading list.
And we are here at lecture 8.
So the two readings today
are risk and insurance
in Village India, my
paper in Econometrica.
And we will cover that in
a fair amount of detail
today, although not
every word, obviously.
And also, chapter 2 in
Medieval Village Economy.
So that's the reading list.
So today is lecture
8, and that is here.
So risk-sharing
applications-- we're
going to do two
different economies using
the same theory, although
the questions to be
asked, though related, are
a little bit different.
One is Village India using
consumption and income
data, which I refer to
as an ex-post version
of the implications of
the risk-sharing model,
and also, as anticipated,
the medieval village economy,
where we're going to talk
about dividing up the land.
And you've seen
maps of this before,
but we didn't have
all of the tools we
needed to really do a good job.
But we do now.
OK.
So for India, here's the
motivation from my paper.
A large part of the population
in developing countries
live in high-risk environments.
That said, there are numerous
ways to cope with it.
One is to diversify the
activities you're undertaking--
trying to have a
portfolio, as it were--
or ex-post, after
incomes get realized,
to engage in financial
transactions,
including gifts and transfers
among family and family
networks.
How well do any one of these
ex-post or ex-ante mechanisms
work?
Well, the main, quote,
"insight" of the paper
was that we really
don't necessarily
have to enumerate the mechanism.
We just look at the outcome.
I'll qualify that a
little bit, and we
can keep coming back to this.
If they diversified perfectly
and everyone had a balanced
portfolio, then they would
all have the same outcome,
and there would be no
further risk to share.
So in some sense,
what we're going
to go through today would not
have much content in the sense
that today, we're
referring to risk sharing,
but it's not done, per se, by
sharing risk after the fact.
It's done by ex-ante
diversification.
Anyway, those two
strands to repeat
are going to be in
today's lecture.
We're going to do the
ex-post part first,
which assumes partial but
not complete diversification,
and then look at
how they could do
it ex-ante with partial but
potentially not complete
diversification.
All right.
So characteristics of village
economies as in India--
very risky place, in large part
because agriculture does not
provide a stable
source of income.
There's a lot of
risk, idiosyncratic
and aggregate risk.
Households diversify
in many ways.
One-- not planting
all of the same crops.
And we are going to use
this benchmark which
assumes there's no information
problem, no moral hazard
problem, no contract
enforcement problem.
All of those words at
this point in the class
don't make a whole lot
of sense because we
haven't studied anything but
these frictionless economies.
But that was the premise.
And again, to anticipate
subsequent lectures,
today we'll see how
well this theory does
without any of these frictions.
And then subsequent
literature has
started to assume things
like contract enforcement
and information
asymmetries, but we are not
going to do that today.
So how do they diversify?
Well, in a village
Aurepalle, which
was under the auspices of
the Institute for Crops
in the Semi-Arid
Tropics, ICRISAT, farmers
are a poly-growth sorghum.
They grow castor.
Sorghum is a grain like wheat.
Castor you may have heard
of as in castor oil.
It's both used in
diet, but also, it
turns out to be a
lubricant for jet engines.
Anyway, the coefficients of
variation are 0.5 and about 1.
Now, you may not remember
that in medieval villages,
we talked about a
very risky environment
with the coefficient
of variation of yields
of about 0.35 or something
like that, which delivered
a disaster every 12 years.
So it's more risky than
that taking any one crop
one at a time.
But they can
diversify over crops.
So looking at the
crop correlation,
those numbers range
from 0.09 to 0.81.
At .09, it's almost the
case that the yields
on one type of crop are
independent of the yields
on the other one.
Again, you can go back and look
at the lecture under Consumer
Preferences where we
were introducing risk
and derived these
kinds of statistics.
Soil isn't uniform
either, so even taking
as given that they're
going to do castor,
they can plant it in one
type of soil or another.
Each type is risky with a
coefficient of variation
from 0.7 to, again,
a little over 1.
But you can diversify
over soil as well
with a correlation of only 0.37,
so pretty good diversification
possibilities.
That said, households don't hold
completely balanced portfolios
across soils and crops.
One household will plant more
of one crop than the other,
or for castor, have more of
one type of soil than the other
despite all the
diversification possibilities.
And going outwards from crops
to other income-generating
activities, they can
engage in wage labor.
They can do trade in
handicrafts or animal husbandry.
So for example, trade in
handicrafts in Aurepalle
consists of climbing
palm trees to get
the fruit from which they will
make palm liquor, for example.
And it's a pretty
specialized activity.
It looks like telephone
repairmen climbing poles
with pretty heavy
and fancy equipment.
Animal husbandry consists of
grazing animals and so on.
Anyway, if you look at
how much land they hold,
it varies from no land at all to
being a small holder or medium
or large holder.
And so for example,
not surprisingly,
the more land they
have, the more
is their income from crops,
going from about 2% to 56%
of the total income.
Likewise, when they hold very
little land, most of the income
is from labor, wage
labor, and that
drops to 4% for the rich
guys, large landholders
in the village, and so on.
Those patterns are pretty
much repeated in the other two
villages, and
Kanzara especially.
Shirapur is much
flatter in the sense
that we don't see very
sharp gradients in terms
of percentage of income
from various sources
as we move from small.
So villages are
kind of a metaphor.
Villages are not all alike.
But the techniques
we're going to use today
do take into account
the differences.
Now let's look at
diversification
over income sources the way we
did for crops and soil types.
This is a little bit difficult
to read, and I'll tell you why.
Going down the diagonal here
is the coefficient of variation
of each income source.
So for example,
crop production is
quite risky with a coefficient
of 0.42, which I almost
said a minute ago.
Of livestock income, the
CV is 0.21, et cetera.
Now, these other off
diagonal elements
here represent the covariation.
So what would have
been better would
have been to list profits,
livestock, income,
earned wages, and
trade and handicrafts
going down the rows,
and then picking
a row, move across the column
to find the covariance.
So for example, this guy
here is the covariance
between profits from crop
production and livestock
income.
And it's actually negative.
So huge diversification
possibilities for a household
if they were doing both
crops and livestock.
These lower
off-diagonal elements
are not filled in because
the matrix is symmetric.
The covariation of
activity i with activity j
is the same as the
variation of i with i.
So it would be redundant
to fill them all in,
and they were deleted to
make it easier to read.
So taking into account different
soils, different crops,
different income sources,
piling them all together,
and plotting income over
the 10 years for which we
have the data, we look
what happens over time
from 1976 to 1985, essentially.
And what's getting
plotted is not just
the time series
of one household.
All of them are
getting plotted here.
In fact, the way
the data were coded,
low numbers correspond
to little or no land,
and high numbers
correspond to lots of land.
So as we move backwards
along the household number,
the households are
getting more and more land
and are actually--
net worth is going up.
So that 1% of the
population that
owns 50% of the wealth,
that's this guy back here.
Now, I refer to this graph
as the Rocky Mountains
because you can
see all the peaks--
well, not quite.
I was going to say you can
see all the peaks and valleys.
That's wrong.
When you have a peak, you
can't see the valley behind it.
If all these incomes
communed with each other,
then everyone's peak would
happen at the same time,
and it would look like waves.
Instead, we see this rather
jagged, sharp picture.
And again, when you're able
to see the valley behind,
it's because there's not
a peak in front of it.
Now, the other thing is
moving along this gradient--
I should have pointed this out
earlier-- there is a 0 here.
This 0 corresponds to the
overall average of income
both over households
and over time.
So these guys are
below-average income.
These guys behind it are
higher-average income.
And again, you can see
that that's quite a salient
gradient.
Here is the corresponding
picture for grain.
And I could have plotted
all consumption items,
but it would have
looked similar.
The paper actually does that.
When I say corresponding, I
mean the scale hasn't changed.
The scale that was used to
plot income, 4,000 at the peak,
is the same as the scale that's
being used to plot consumption.
So you can see everybody's
consumption is compressed,
so they're smoothing.
They're smoothing over time.
And to a degree
there, a large degree,
they're actually smoothing
over households as well.
Those very wealthy
guys are consuming
more than the poor guys
but not nearly as much
as income is higher for them
relative to income of low guys.
The main point of
the picture, however,
is that here, you can
almost see the waves.
Grain consumption is
kind of co-moving.
That would be easier to
see if we blew it up,
but we will look at
this statistically
as well in a few
subsequent slides.
And I refer to this as Kansas.
I don't if any of you
have ever been in Kansas.
I ask this every time
I teach this diagram.
At one point, some
student in the class
said, I'm from Kansas.
And I said, oh, I'm sorry.
I hope I haven't insulted you.
And he said, no, no.
It is really boring there.
So I like Kansas.
I'm not saying that.
But anyway, amber
waves of grain,
so consumption versus income.
So let's think about
a theory to try
to explain the difference
between those two diagrams.
And this is the bit that's
a little bit of a review,
but I think a useful one.
So we're going to talk
about individual k
alive at date t
that has experienced
a history of shocks ht.
This history is the shock at
date 1, the shock at date 2,
and the shock at date 3.
So again, this is the
state space representation
of the tree that
you saw in Debreu,
and I featured at
least twice already.
What is the objective function?
We're going to solve
that programming problem
to go back and forth between
solutions to that problem
in Pareto optimal allocations.
So we're going to maximize
a lambda-weighted sum
of discounted
expected utilities,
weighted lambda k for weight
k over all the individuals
and their capital M of them.
The contemporary utility
functions have as arguments
the consumption of individual k
at date thq, which we just did,
and then this age-gender index.
So not everyone is the same age.
Not everyone is the same gender.
18-year-old males
eat twice as much
as anybody else, essentially.
So we want to adjust
the utility for
these metabolic requirements.
And they may not be treating
the women very equitably either.
But we are going to take these
as metabolic weights that were
measured in a dietary survey.
So the other objects
here are the probability
of that history
actually happening.
Note that for any day t, we
sum over all possible histories
that could have generated
that node at date t.
And then in addition,
there are multiple dates,
so we sum over those dates
and discount them by beta.
And again, the lambdas
are the Pareto weights
that vary between 0 and
1, and they sum to 1,
and we take the weighted sum.
There are many, many
resource constraints.
There is a particular
constraint for every date t
and all possible
histories that could
have led to t that simply
says that the way you hand out
consumption must not
sum to something greater
than the total that's available.
So usually, we
talk about income.
Now we just went to
total expenditure.
But obviously, whatever
income is, if it were spent,
it would lead to
expenditure, and then you
could reallocate it.
And some people might be
consuming more than others.
But here we take the total
aggregate consumption as fixed.
We're not going to
put labor in here.
There's just consumption.
And we get first-order
conditions.
So if you pick a particular
consumption for a household
k at day t as a function
of a particular history ht,
it would appear in the
w contemporary utility
function with the prime for the
derivative weighted by lambda k
And that beta to the
t probability of ht
would also be over there,
but we've multiplied through.
So that now becomes a
term in the denominator.
And the numerator
term here is mu.
So let me go back.
So the mu is the
Lagrange multiplier
on this resource constraint.
And it really should have a mu
indexed by t and the history
h of t because there is
a constraint like this
for every single possible
history end date.
So there are many,
many constraints.
That's why I caught
myself when I
said subject to one constraint.
That's wrong.
There's only one
good, but there's
many dates and many states.
The mu that's appearing here--
I didn't write an
additional little t which
ought to be there probably.
But anyway, mu tilde is
the normalized version
after dividing through
by the discount
rate and the probability.
And if you started with
particular utility functions
like one of our favorites,
constant exponential utility,
where sigma is the
degree of risk aversion,
it is of this form.
Now, there is a step
that's happening here
which is imposing the way
that these age and gender
weights are entering into
the utility function.
Namely, it's consumption
per unit index.
So pick a 30-year-old male
and then look at the other age
groups and the other genders.
And the question
is whether they're
consuming more or consuming
less than that baseline case.
So we, for short, can talk about
this consumption per unit age.
That's really the object that's
entering into individual K's
utility function.
And c tilde then replaces
that normalized consumption c
over a.
And when you do the math, you'll
get the consumption formula,
the risk-sharing
formula, as it were.
So this is the
per-unit consumption
of household
individual K at date t.
It has an intercept
term, a term that
depends on the
demographics, and a term
that depends on this Pareto,
this shadow price mu.
You've kind of seen this
before, but let me remind you
this intercept term,
quite logically, has
to do with the Pareto weight.
The higher is the Pareto
weight of individual K,
the higher is the log
of the Pareto weight,
it's normalized by this
degree of risk aversion.
If we move over
here to the mu term,
mu is the shadow
price of consumption.
It's how much the
objective function
would increase if you
increase consumption
by an infinitesimally small
amount in the aggregate.
So as mu goes up,
consumption is going down.
Why is that?
Mu is the shadow price.
So the lower is
aggregate consumption.
The higher will be
the shadow price.
So as mu goes up, there's
less consumption to go around,
so individual consumption
is also dropping.
And we will replace this
by aggregate consumption
and get a positive
sign momentarily.
The other interesting
thing about this equation
is, again, this 1 over sigma
which I feature in this term,
although it's on all
the other ones as well.
And that is if individual
risk aversion goes up,
this coefficient is going down.
So as risk aversion goes
up, this individual K
should not experience
too much variation
in his or her consumption
when the aggregate is moving
because other people would
be in a better position
to absorb the aggregate
shock if they were
less-risk averse
than individual K.
And again, you'll
see that momentarily.
Questions?
STUDENT: My question
is why there
was a negative sign before
the A, log A, the age and sex
index.
It looks like in the utility
function when A goes up,
the utility will go up.
ROBERT TOWNSEND:
When A is going up,
though, consumption per
unit age is going down.
STUDENT: But in the
utility function--
ROBERT TOWNSEND: And they're
becoming more urgent,
so to speak, other things equal.
So I'm sorry.
I think I said it
right the first time.
Holding aggregate consumption
fixed, for example,
as their index is going up,
the consumption per unit index
is going down.
And that's the negative sign.
It's really just that simple.
All right.
But thank you for
asking the question.
All right.
Now, that was just
one individual.
We can put all the individuals
together and allow explicitly
for different risk aversion.
And this formula
appears in the paper,
and I'm not going
to try to derive it.
It's somewhat tedious algebra.
But the interpretation is easy.
Namely, there's an
intercept, something
to do with demographics,
and something
to do with aggregate
consumption.
In a little bit more
detail, this is no longer
individual I consumption.
It's all the individuals
in a household J.
And unfortunately, that's
all we see in the data.
We don't see individual eating
apart from that dietary survey.
We just see aggregate
household consumption.
But that functional
form allowed us
to sum up over all
the consumptions,
and that's what we see.
And we also have the age
and sex of all the members.
So we also have the denominator.
So this is household-level
consumption per unit age.
And that should be higher.
The higher is household
J's lambda weight
relative to the lambda
weights of the other people
in the village.
It's a bit more complicated
because these lambda weights
are weighted by the
degree of risk aversion.
So it's a risk-aversion-weighted
version of the Lambda
that we care about,
comparing it to lambda
K. This is the demographic.
I may come back to that.
This is the formula now in
terms of aggregate consumption.
This is the consumption of
individual K and household J--
I, actually-- but then
summing over all households I.
So this is aggregate
consumption per unit age
in the whole village.
And again, you can see quite
explicitly that J's consumption
will move with that when
sigma J is going down,
or the other way around--
when household J is very risk
averse, this coefficient
is going to 0,
and individual
consumption would not
very much with the aggregate.
That's the aggregate
allocation of risk bearing.
Because the theory has those
age and gender weights in it,
you can treat those as shocks.
Even though they're quite
not moving in a surprise way,
they are moving over time.
They're moving intertemporally,
and maybe the whole village
is getting older.
Maybe one household is moving
across metabolic categories
faster than the
other households are.
And so the formula allows
for that adjustment,
comparing household
j to the other ones.
So let's look at an empirical
implication, a linear equation.
The aggregate consumption,
age weighted, of household
J has an intercept.
It depends on
aggregate consumption.
It depends on the
index of household J
and maybe on other things.
This is just a version of this.
Household J's
consumption depends
on an intercept, its age,
and aggregate consumption.
It's just much easier
to write this way.
And the theory has implications.
Namely, if everyone had
the same risk aversion,
then this beta J on aggregate
consumption would be 1.
You can convince
yourself this would
be 1 because the sigmas
are all alike, for example.
Likewise, this demographic thing
would have a coefficient of 1
over sigma, the common sigma.
And this other stuff--
I saved the best for last.
This is any other variable,
including household income.
And the theory is saying that
this coefficient should be 0.
Now, that's very
counterintuitive.
How could I possibly be claiming
that household consumption
doesn't depend on
household income?
What about marginal propensity
to consume and all of that?
Well, the answer is they're
pooling their incomes together
as if in a mutual fund
and then redistributing it
as a function of
the Pareto weights.
So household J's income
is kind of in there,
but it's in the pooled
version, and it shows up
in aggregate consumption.
And if you control for that,
then there's nothing leftover.
There's no idiosyncratic
risk for household J to bear.
Another way to say
that is we're going
to get perfect
consumption insurance
because, like a
large mutual fund,
all the individual
shocks go to 0.
A version of this in China
that I'm becoming aware of--
Alibaba runs a mutual
fund over health shocks.
There's 100 million
households joining,
and they pay ex-post premia.
Typical medical expense
must be as high as $20,000.
How much do they pay in?
$9 in yuan equivalent.
So when you spread that damage
of an individual household,
which is high, over
all the hundreds
of thousands of households,
it almost goes to 0.
And this is the extreme
version of perfect pooling.
That's contemporary China, not
a village in India in 1985.
So we can test the theory by
looking at each household one
at a time over the 10 years,
and we can test the theory
by pooling households
together into one
big cross-sectional
time-dependent regression.
This is a little hard to
see, but what's going on here
statistically is testing
these coefficients xe, which
should be 0, to see whether
they actually are in practice.
Under the null
hypothesis that it's 0,
can you reject in a
statistically significant way
that it's greater
than 0 or less than 0?
And for most households,
the bulk of the households,
you can't reject much
one way or the other.
There's just a
handful of households
on either side of the null.
This test has power.
This thing is, oh, well,
maybe it's just noisy data,
and we can't infer
much of anything.
Maybe they're literally
hand-to-mouth,
and they're eating entirely
their income, in which case
the coefficient would be 1.
And we can't reject
that for half of them.
But for the other half,
we can statistically
reject that it's 1.
So there is a lot of
smoothing going on.
And this is for the other
two villages down here.
Now let's talk about
pooling it together.
Actually, let's just jump
here, and then I'll go back.
So here's the villages--
Aurepalle, Shirapur, Kandara.
And we're going to somehow
take each household over time
and take households
in the cross-section
and come up with a
coefficient on how much
consumption is moving on
average with household income.
And the answer is roughly--
should be in rupees--
$0.07 for the dollar.
So for every dollar
change in income,
consumption is
moving by only $0.07.
It's positive.
It's statistically significant.
We now reject the model.
But as an approximation,
we're doing
quite well because these
coefficients are small.
So most, although
not all, of the
household-specific idiosyncratic
risk is being pooled.
And you can peruse
this table and see--
this is profits as opposed
to all income, labor income,
profits from trade
and handicraft.
You can look for
the high numbers.
So there are certain
activities in certain villages
that look relatively
under-insured.
This is who's the
most vulnerable.
If we had the ability
to come in externally
and introduce a better
insurance product,
we would want to offer it
to households that need it.
Or if no one needed it, we
would expect take-up to be zero.
So labor incomes had a pretty
high coefficient in Shirapur
and so on.
But a lot of these are 0--
that is to say, not
statistically different from 0.
So in that sense, it's
a good approximation.
Remember, according to Lucas,
models are abstractions.
They're meant to be stylized
versions of reality.
Because we have a model,
we have an exact prediction
of what we should expect to see.
And through the
lens of the model,
we can decide how reality is
doing relative to the model.
So I'm not overly
alarmed that we're going
to get statistical rejections.
The question is, is it
a useful starting point
as an approximation?
And the answer seems to be yes.
I will share with you that
when I wrote this paper,
it kind of created
a firestorm of alarm
among policymakers
who were astounded
that poor households in villages
in the caste system, and so on,
could ever possibly be achieving
anything close to an optimum.
It just went against the grain
of their prior presumptions.
But it doesn't fit perfectly.
So this slide which I
deliberately skipped over just
now is to say, look,
maybe I'm getting
into statistical stuff a bit,
and we can follow up later.
One reason why this
coefficient might be low
is because this variable
x is very poorly measured.
Say it just got a lot
of measurement error
that is not real.
Then it's moving around a
lot for spurious reasons,
and you would not expect that
to influence consumption.
So that biases this coefficient
to something close to 0.
Fortunately, we can correct
for it with the panel.
And it's putting explicitly
this measurement error
into, in this case,
idiosyncratic income
and then substituting
that into those equations.
We now see a correlation
between the measurement error
and the measured
version of income,
which means you can't
run an OLS regression.
But on the other hand,
another way to do this
is just to take
first differences.
Differences over
time over households
gives you another version.
And it turns out this
within coefficient
and this across-time coefficient
allow you to essentially get
rid of the measurement error.
So that's this IV
Griliches-Hausman thing,
which I'm not going to go over.
I still don't know what the
best strategy is for me.
If I skip stuff, then it looks
like it came out of nowhere,
and you don't really
understand it.
Hence, I try in all
these slides to show you
the steps that are being taken.
I'm deliberately not
concealing something from you.
But on the other hand,
this particular sequence
involves statistical material
you may not have seen
something similar to before.
So if it's still quite opaque,
don't worry too much about it.
I'm just trying to be clearer.
OK.
So that's summary, risk and
insurance and village India.
These villages are
doing reasonably well,
although not perfectly.
They're sharing a
lot of the risk.
The reason that
consumption looks so flat
relative to income is because
they're actively, somehow
or another, engaged in
borrowing and lending
or transfers to bridge the gap
between consumption and income.
Now, another way they could
handle the situation--
so for this, we're going to
jump to medieval villages--
is to potentially
divide up the land.
So this is the
diversification part,
whether land holdings
of a typical village
would be consistent with the
optimal allocation of risk
predicted in that model
just now on the premise
that what you get
is what you eat.
You have these strips.
The strips are subject to risk.
You add it all up across
all your land holdings,
then you eat it.
So this is the other extreme--
no expo smoothing,
no credit markets.
Even going back to lecture 1
or something where I presented
all the different
economies-- we talked
about the medieval
village economy.
We're about to do it now in
terms of dividing up the land.
We also talked about
Thai village economy
with that temple where
households did not diversify.
Some had low land.
Some had high land.
They made donations
to the temple.
And people that had a
bad year, God gives back.
So the second thing is
what's going on in the first,
some mechanism for
risk sharing ex-post.
This is the mechanism
in the second, which
is ex-ante division of land.
I said that in reverse
order, but anyway.
So you've seen this
picture twice before.
This is Elford Stratfordshire.
Mr. Darlaston's land
is shaded in black,
and he's got something like 50
strips throughout the village.
So why were they doing that--
not just Mr. Darlaston, but
all of them to some degree?
So if you think about
this map, for example,
are these types of
land differ in some way
from these types of land
in terms of soil or slope
or elevation?
Or alternatively,
land is all alike.
And then the question is, when
the storm comes and destroys
crops, it could destroy
these crops and not these.
So there's really
two different models,
and we're only going
to have time to do one,
although the other
one is covered
in that missing medieval
village chapter.
We're going to do uniform
shocks on non-uniform land,
and the non-uniform shocks
we'll save for another time.
So there are two types of land.
Start off keeping this simple.
Say high-low or clay-sandy.
There's only two households,
another abstraction.
And there's only one date.
And land type k has
a yield vector which
varies with the shock epsilon.
And epsilon can take
on capital S values.
So this epsilon is a measure
of rainfall, temperature,
humidity, or other
events which have
beneficial or adverse
consequences for the yield
as captured by the way which
the yield of type k land
varies with those shocks.
You've, again, seen
this before a bit.
When we did the dynamics,
we planted land with seed
and talked about how the yield
could vary with low, medium,
and high shock.
So this is very
similar notation.
Now, let's be serious
even though we're
trying to keep this simple.
What numbers do we
use for this vector?
One thing we want to
capture is how much
that yield is varying as
measured by the coefficient
of variation.
And in medieval villages,
it was about 0.35,
which we've covered
before, and I'm not
going to go back and dig
up those slides for you.
But that was the
number we used before.
The other one is--
there's two types of land
here, k equal 1 or 2.
And we want to choose
vectors of returns for both.
So we want to capture
the covariance
in the two types of land,
how different are they
from one another.
And again, going back in the
earlier lecture, the estates
of the Bishop of Winchester, we
had a cross-space correlation
of 0.6.
So we're going to take
those numbers, .6 and .347,
as givens.
But here's a simple
representation.
Let's take, again,
only two types
of land, 1 or 2, only three
events, epsilon equal 1, 2, 3.
Type 1 land has the highest
return in event 1, then medium,
then low.
Type 2 land has
the highest return
at event 2 surrounded by
the lower numbers, 3 and 2.
So if you aggregated up the
total yield over all types,
it would just be the
sum of those columns.
And it would go 12, 10, 7.
Now suppose we divided
up the types of land
in a very extreme way.
We let household 1
have all of type 1 land
and household two
all of type 2 land.
And the question for you
is whether that would be
an optimal allocation of land.
If we did it that way
and they were forced
to eat the grain
off their strips,
would the consumption
that we see
correspond to the
implications of the model?
And the answer is going to be no
because the aggregate is going
down as epsilon is going up.
And that's true of
household 1's consumption,
but it is not true of
household 2's consumption.
This proposal fails the
monotonicity requirement
of the theory that as
aggregate consumption
goes down everybody's
consumption ought
to go down, although some
people's consumption go
down more than others.
So we reject this proposal
for the allocation of land
if the goal is to achieve an
optimal allocation of risk
bearing by land division alone.
Well, there are
other ways to do it.
Let's take the land type
and give household J
a proportional number
of shares in the output
of each type of land.
So that means
household J would get
fraction alpha J of the
output over each type of land.
So we're kind of
re-dividing things here.
We're going to have
household 1 getting
some proportion of this column
but also some proportion,
not necessarily-- yes,
in this case, the same
of the other type of land.
So this alpha J
doesn't have a K on it.
The shares depend
only on the household,
not on the type of land.
The shares can depend
on the household.
All right.
So it's linear in the aggregate.
If we were over at school,
you'd come up to my office,
and you'll see my
bookshelf filled
with stacks of books devoted
to medieval English villages.
I had a happy time
doing a lot of research.
And you'd discover
these amazing things.
Holdings were
scattered over fields
so that each household
partook in equal proportion
of fertilizer and poor soils.
Dividing up the
land in accordance
with drainage and
exposure, resources
were divided into shares.
One man might have more
shares than another,
but the shares
themselves were equal.
Now, there are
potential problems.
For the theory to
fit exactly, we
got to worry a little
bit about the intercepts
because those divisions did
not allow the intercepts to be
other than 0.
If you go back to where we
first introduced risk sharing
and looked at particular
utility functions,
I showed you, as example
of the risk-sharing rules,
two equations--
constant relative risk
aversion, constant
absolute risk aversion.
And the intercept was 0
under these various types
of conditions.
So it's not like
they can't be 0,
but it does require
certain parameters
to hold in order for
that to be the case.
So a little bit of
a qualification.
But all is not lost.
We can even do more.
And namely, we don't have to
have a given household having
the same number of shares
in every type of land.
And that's going to allow
various kinds of intercepts
and so on.
So here's the idea finally.
Suppose there are at
least as many land types
with independent return vectors
as there are states of nature.
So what I showed you
just now violated that.
There were three states of
nature and two types of land.
But if we had three
states of nature,
we'd have to have
three types of land
with independent return streams.
And likewise, s types
of land, we need
s dimensional return vectors.
So one column cannot be
derived as a linear combination
of the other columns.
Now let's solve the
risk-sharing problem
and take this consumption to
be the target, this consumption
of household J in state epsilon.
And we're going to do that,
obviously, over all states
epsilon and all households
j, their little n of them.
We get an equation of this form.
So don't get lost
in the notation.
I'll help.
This is consumption of household
J in state 1, consumption
of household J in state 2,
likewise in state capital S.
That's a target.
And just imagine it
solved the Pareto problem.
How can we achieve it?
We have as controls the
fraction of type k land held
by household J. And now
those fractions, alpha j,
vary with k.
So we're allowing
land-type-specific allocation
of shares.
Anyway, if you do the
linear algebra here,
here's the yield of
type 1 land in state
1, the yield of type 2
land in state 1, et cetera.
These alphas would
then multiply--
e1, alpha 1, e2,
alpha 2, et cetera.
So adding it up like
the dot product,
we would get consumption.
Consumption is coming from
a share-weighted version
of the yield.
Hopefully, the algebra is clear.
Writing it in matrix
notation, we just
want to get this
quote endowment matrix
e times the share vector for
household J varying over type k
land.
It's a vector equal to the
state-dependent consumptions.
So e times alpha equals cj.
So then the question is,
to achieve this target,
can we find alphas that do it?
And that's like
solving this equation.
So essentially, take an
inverse of something.
If there are as many return
vectors over types of land
that are independent of each
other as there are states,
then this matrix has an inverse.
It's non-singular, so you
can solve this equation.
So now we'll have
solutions for the alphas.
And it turns out if you do
that not just for household j
but over all of them,
you'll get an implication
that the sum of the
alphas will add up to 1.
So they do look like shares.
Type k land held in fraction
alpha j by the j-th household
when summed over-- there
should be a sum here--
there was one there--
when summed over
j would equal 1.
So all the land is divided.
All the land of each
type k is totally divided
among all the households.
You could run into a
little bit of problem
if the alphas went
negative because then
that's like trying to go short.
We're not going to
allow that to happen.
So there's a little bit
of a fly in the ointment.
But roughly speaking,
there's a way
to achieve an optimal allocation
of risk sharing just by shares.
So they don't need to
transfer risk around ex post.
They can do it all ex ante.
Now, in order to
achieve that, we
had to ignore the
negative alphas.
But more to the point,
we had to assume
there are as many
types of land as there
are states of the world.
Maybe that's not true.
I don't know.
It could go both ways.
How many different
types of land are there,
and how many different states
can a given land type take on?
If there's incredible
heterogeneity over land,
it's entirely possible
that the number of types
was equal if not greater
than the number of states.
But I could also imagine
the other way around.
Like the Thai village, you've
got low land and high land.
You put them in two
categories, and then you
have multiple states.
You'd have an
incomplete version.
Let's see how bad it is, though.
Maybe as an approximation,
they were doing pretty well
by dividing up the
land even if they
couldn't achieve the optimal
allocation perfectly.
So let's put in two
different utility functions.
For household 1, we have
constant relative risk
aversion, and for household
2, it's a quadratic function.
This quadratic thing is
a pain and always scary
when you see it.
It's like there's a bliss point.
We've talked about this.
Consumption is less
than the bliss point
assumed so that the marginal
utility of consumption
is always positive.
Otherwise, you see a
lot of negative signs,
and it's kind of disturbing.
Can this consumption be
higher than the bliss point?
No, because you'll get marginal
utility being negative,
moving negatively
with consumption.
So anyway, just so you feel
a bit more comfortable,
let's put in alpha equal
to 0.5, k equal 0.002,
and be equal to 80.
So we have completely
parameterized this family
of utility functions.
And again, we have
different preferences here
but nice concave utility,
strictly, for both.
We've got two types of land,
and we're back to, say,
having three or more
states of the world.
So ex ante division into
shares cannot work perfectly.
To see how far we get, we
constrain the programming
problem to nevertheless
search over these shares,
alpha jk of household
J share of type k land.
And we maximize a
lambda-weighted sum
of ex ante expected utilities.
Oh, well there's only one date
here, so ignore the dynamics.
But there are multiple states.
And we're going to max this
thing subject to shares
can't go negative, and
they have to add up to 1.
So it's a constrained
programming problem.
We could call the solution
to this constrained optimal.
It's constrained by the
premise that the mechanism only
allows ex-ante
division into shares
and not ex-post consumption
transfers, not gifts, not
borrowing and lending, nothing.
Now, you know from
our work on Pareto
optimal allocations there's
going to be a Pareto frontier.
So it's not like
there's one solution.
It's going to vary
with the lambdas.
So we'll do something
special as an example, which
is to maximize the
utility of household 1
subject to the
utility of household
2 at an arbitrary constant.
So let me show you a picture,
and then I'll go back.
We're in utility space,
so we have the utilities
of household 1 and household 2.
And we have-- if we didn't
have a constrained problem,
we'd have this outer
frontier of the set
of all possible utilities
on the boundary.
And we'll call that the utility
at the full risk sharing.
There are many solutions.
We got these through
hyperplanes previously.
There is an equivalent
way to do it,
which is to fix the utility
of one household, namely 2,
and maximize the utility
of the other one.
So we would end up right here.
But in the constrained
problem, we're
limited to dividing
up land by shares.
That constrained Pareto
frontier is interior, still
a bit concave.
And we would move,
therefore, from where
that horizontal utility
level for household 2
hits the outer frontier
versus the inner frontier.
So let's focus on
the inner frontier,
the constrained
problem, and then see
how close they're going to
get to the outer frontier.
I solved that thing numerically.
I was trying to give you all
the parameters for utility
functions.
Some of it's missing
here-- covariance,
coefficient of variation.
And you get a solution that
household 1 has about 3/4,
72%, of land type I 2 and
about a quarter of land type 2.
And household 2 would
be on the other side
of this at roughly 1/4, 3/4.
So one thing to
note is that that
generates a non-linear sharing
rule but non-optimal rule.
I think I missed--
when I presented this
constraint problem,
I neglected the little
paragraph at the bottom.
No, it's not there.
Well, let me remind you.
Again, back to the preference
lecture where we did risk,
and I showed you two
particular utility functions,
constant exponential and
constant relative risk aversion
with linear schedules.
But then I showed you another
figure which was non-linear--
monotone increasing for both
households, but nonlinear.
That came from this
specification of utilities.
So that's what I was looking
for, seen in previous lecture
7.
So we know the optimal
sharing rules are nonlinear.
Dividing up into shares
suggests we're going
to end up with linear rules.
So we're not going to
end up with the optimum.
But we can still
try to figure out
how close the inner frontier
is to the outer frontier.
So let's look at the transfers.
Let me state this clearly.
We're going to try to do it
ex-ante by division of shares,
get the constrained
optimum, and then look
at transfers across the
two households, who's
paying who depending
on the state, and then
finally, how those transfers
would need potentially
to be augmented.
So here's the
aggregate endowment.
This is the sum of the yields
over the two types of land.
That's also
aggregate consumption
because this is
a static problem.
Here is consumption of
the individual agents,
both of them.
This is the consumption
of person 1, constrained,
linear dotted line.
Here's the consumption
of person 2.
Constrained is this dot
dashed line for person 2.
Constrained is the
dot-dot-dot line for person 1.
They're both linear schedules.
Now, remember, they're not
doing this with transfers--
I kind of misspoke
a minute ago--
because they're doing it with
ex-ante division into shares.
But nevertheless, it's not
the full-blown optimum.
It's not the outer frontier
in which you can not only
have division but
also ex-post transfers
to get to the full optimum.
And those schedules are
listed here as unconstrained.
And they are non-linear, as
I was trying to say earlier.
So if we look at these
states, say five states,
and look at consumption under
ex-ante division of land
versus consumption under the
full optimum, for household 1,
you can see household
1 is monotonic.
Household consumption
is logically
increasing with the
aggregate, but it's
a bit different,
although monotonic,
from what it would be
under the full optimum.
And here you can see
at the lowest state,
household 1 would be consuming
more under the full optimum
but then less under the
full optimum relative
to the division, less, and
then back to being more.
So here it is over here.
Why am I struggling so hard?
So this is the amount
of the transfer
from household 2
to household 1 that
is necessary to add
on to the solution
from the ex-ante division
of land shares only.
If you wanted to look
at it in a picture,
the picture is
literally the difference
between these two lines.
So here, the amount
that household 1
ought to be getting under the
full optimum would be higher,
and therefore, ought to
get a positive transfer.
Here, it would be lower,
hence the negative transfer.
And finally, at the
end, positive again.
So that's consistent
with these numbers
where these states,
going from 1 to 5,
is like moving across
the different values
of the aggregate endowment.
So in summary, I guess
there is a couple
of takeaways from the
second half of this lecture.
One, we looked at special
mechanisms-- in this case,
ex-ante division of land
and whether or not we
could get to an
optimal allocation
of risk bearing that way.
And we saw some special
cases where could.
We had to make the shares
different across the different
households and maybe different
across the different land
types, especially so if we
accommodated more and more
diversity and preferences.
The second takeaway
from the second part
is we might not
achieve a full optimum,
so we would have expected some
kind of borrowing and lending
and gift-giving in that
medieval village economy
even if we can't find it
in the historical records.
Or we could just say, evidently,
for institutional reasons
we don't understand, they
just weren't doing it.
But we don't lose our tools.
Not all is lost.
We are still able to solve for
a constrained optimal allocation
solving the so-called Pareto
problem or programming
problem, maximizing
lambda-weighted sums of utility
subject to constraints with the
appropriate control variables,
in this case shares.
And then the big
picture of this lecture
is we're looking
at the application
of the theory of the optimal
allocation of risk bearing.
We did that in
villages in India,
looking at consumption
and income data.
So from a science point
of view, we have a model.
We have data.
The data can vary
across the applications.
You can still ask,
even if we don't
have the data on
everything, whether we can
see how well the theory fits.
And we could do that in--
in the medieval
villages, we don't even
have data on consumption
of individual households,
and all we see are
pictures of land.
But we do have the covariance
and variance statistics.
So we're kind of
able to calibrate
the model a bit the way we were
calibrating the dynamic storage
model, but in this
case, not to try
to explain why they didn't
store very often, but rather,
to explain this very salient
pattern of dividing land
into different strips.
OK.
So that's all I have for today.
All right.
See you soon.
Thank you so much.